so i'm assuming that we're never gonna
get the drake song it's never gonna see
the light of day um and i don't know but
you know what
probably not maybe just the moment
passed
that's what i think to be honest with
you that's what i really think i think
the moment passed but it's a dope song
it's always songs like that the thing
about me did it leak
yeah hell yeah so it so people can go
listen to it so yeah people can go
listen so this damn route
it's a dope record but i think it might
be more opportunities to do [ __ ] and
people heard it most people who need to
hear they heard the record already you
know i've heard it i like the little
fake name they call it what they call it
uh buffalo something i don't know i just
heard it when you played it for me i i
just found out you like you you that
naked
no i found i i found that at elites
recently and i was like oh i had no idea
it leaked yeah the moment passed when
i'm saying everybody was hype about it
and [ __ ] like that but if we drop that
[ __ ] right now on dsp should've
should've gone crazy but just cause
people want to hear us together that's
the thing about me like people be
excited when i rap with people or other
people rat with me you know i'm saying
that's what i learned from just watching
how this [ __ ] go